the book was upside down
who noticed yeah so uh
first of all you've been on the show
many times and you always
complain you are a new yorker and you
complain
about the uh traffic of uh of tourists
that walk the streets of manhattan today
can't be a happy day for you
st patrick's day no today is the kind of
zenith
of the unhappy tourist day right
because first of all there used to be a
reason to have this parade here there
used to be many irish people lived here
they don't live here anymore they come
here they come here for the for they
come here for the parade for the place
they used to live right they should have
it there
not come here right they should have it
on long island where they live yeah yeah
instead of coming here uh-huh right
outside my building all of them
they're all outside your building all
outside my building yeah i've noticed
they're focusing on you
now they're going to come looking for
you now that you've said this they've
always come looking for me
well i know it's it's a little
depressing for you this day but i do
envy you you have
you have what i believe to be a nice
thing coming up which is you're a writer
for vanity fair and vanity fair
if you don't know always has the most
amazing oscar party
every year everyone goes to the vanity
fair oscar party you're a writer for
this magazine
you must be going yes i am are you
trying to get in yes
huh i would take you you would i would
take you seriously
absolutely this is this this party is
now what the hell was that i could have
gone if i wanted to anyway
now you have to come now i have to come
exactly well tell me about this party
i've never gotten to go i never get to
go to any parties what's it like
um it's uh it's kind of like today in
new york outside except they're all
movie stars
all movie stars throwing up and painted
green yes
well they're green but it's mostly envy
well so tell us what's it like describe
it for us what's it
it's a parade of movie stars billions of
movie stars the happy ones who won
and then the ones who hate them the
other people who hate them yes
don't you always feel when you watch the
academy awards and the person wins and
the camera always shoots the person who
wednesday you don't want to see that
person you know they're smiling
right you want to see the people who
lost you want to stay close on them for
a long time
people who lost and watch their misery
what the audience wants to see
i want the camera to follow the person
that lost for the next few days that's
right
home home right show them home and bug
their phone
and hear it while they complain right
now there's a isn't there's a there's a
there's a child who's there
i mean what's his name what's the child
actor who's who's up here
that's right haley joel blah blah blah
culkin culkin yes yeah
collin o'neil i'm never holding your
book right side up
what uh yes he's up for an oscar which
has got to be strange
well i think it would be i mean if i was
a movie star um
i would feel a little demean to keep
competing with an eight-year-old child
right
i mean all prizes are kind of in some
way silly
right um or undeserved i believe that
because i've never gotten one
but that's why yes exactly the minute i
get one they will become valid in my
opinion
don't hang by your teeth okay yeah um
i would feel someone to me competing
with an eight-year-old child
right you know it might be you know i
don't know who actually i know the other
people are up but
jack nicholson or this eight-year-old
child right right and many years the
eight-year-old child went
right and i think that would be then you
never hear from them again and the adult
you know it's so must be weird because
they hand the kid an oscar and he can't
possibly
he's going to try and eat it or he's
going to think it's he's going to think
it's chocolate
and there's a 55 year old guy who put
his has his whole life on the line also
the child always thinks this is the
beginning of their great career instead
of the end
is the meanest show we've done in a
while we got some dead leprechauns on
our hands and now we're into this
i mean you if you look back on the
children who've won you feel that the
car that picks them up
after the award ceremony should go
directly to betty ford
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what i can't believe the audience is
horrified by us going after an
eight-year-old come on
well he's not a real eight-year-old he's
an actor he's an actor portraying an
eight-year-old
he's actually he himself is i think 48
years old
very likely uh i'm gonna stick with
holding it upside down
just because i've gotten this far with
it that's fine okay the uh
no i'll do it nicely the fran leibowitz
reader
it is st patrick's day isn't it uh is
available everywhere ladies and
gentlemen go out and get this book fran
thank you very much for being here on
our special st
patrick's day friendly what's everybody
we're gonna take a break we'll be right
back stick around don't leave
you